foreign
[Music]
okay
welcome to this press conference
following the first day of the european
council
where we discussed international matters
i will first give the floor to the
presence
of the european council merced
concentration
[Music]
we also have had the opportunity tonight
to have
in-depth in exchange of views on the
relationship
between the eu and russia we
condemn the russia's illegal provocative
and
disruptive activities we express our
solidarity
with members especially the czech
republic
and the eastern partners we have
reaffirmed
the five guiding principles for this
relationship
with russia and we have decided to ask
to the commission
and to the high representative to
present a
report with policy options
in order for us at the level of european
council to revert
to the matter in june and to
provide clear political orientations
this debate was useful this debate was
fruitful
it was the opportunity to listen to each
other to each other
and also through collective intelligence
uh to make the assessment what's the
current situation
and how we can try to improve the
possibility for the eu
to to defend our interests and to
promote our
values
we fall out in parallel with the
european currency the situation
in mali
[Music]
situations
[Music]
yes thank you indeed the first topic was
the hijacking of the ryanair flight by
belarus authorities
and in the european council the judgment
was unanimous
this is an attack on democracy this is
an attack
on freedom of expression and this is an
attack
on european sovereignty and
this outrageous behavior needs a strong
answer
therefore the european council decided
that there will be additional sanctions
on individuals that are involved
in the hijacking but this time also on
businesses
and economic entities that are financing
this regime and the hijacking of the
place
plane is also a deliberate and
unnecessary triggering of a
safety emergency it is it is
it has involved an unjustified
intervention of a military aircraft
the air navigation service was misused
to
aid the state in taking control of an eu
aircraft and belarus used its control
over its airspace in order to perpetrate
a state hijacking therefore the safety
and security of flights
through belarus airspace can no longer
be trusted
and the council will adapt measures to
ban overflies
of the eu airspace and deny access to
airports to eu airports to belarus
airplanes
roman pratazewicz must be released
immediately
belarus authorities are entirely
responsible for
his health and the health of his
companion sofia zapaga
and there was a very clear and unclear
and unanimous
stance of the european council
concerning that topic
indeed on russia the eu's approach
approached to a russian authorities is
based
on our commonly agreed five principles
that is the full implementation of the
minsk agreement
the engagement with eastern partnership
countries
the strengthening of eu internal
resilience
a selective engagement with russia
and the people-to-people exchanges and
we will continue to stay
on this course we took stock of
our relations leaders all agreed that
russia
is consistently challenging both our
interests
and our values by its actions in the
past but also in the present
we all know the interfering and
destabilization in neighboring countries
such as ukraine moldova georgia
we have seen the the attempt to weaken
the european union and undermine member
states
through hybrid threats sabotage
assassinations
divide and rule tactics cyber attacks
disinformation campaigns
we have seen these patterns for years it
is not changing it is getting worse
at the same time the eu and russia are
bound to a joint future
russia is our largest neighbor and
remains source of
trade and investment to the union
along our common borders the lives of
europeans and russians are
intertwined and russia is an important
player to meet global challenges and
address regional matters in this context
there was the tasking of the high
representative and the commission to
present a report
at the june european council and we will
look at the state of our relations
with russia in light of this report in
the next council
finally the eu uk
relations we held our first discussion
on eu
uk relations since the entry into force
of the
tca the beginnings are not easy
tensions are being felt around the
access for example of eu fishing
boats or tensions are without any doubt
there
around the implementation of the
protocol of northern ireland island
vice president sefkovic is working hard
with our uk counterparts how to resolve
the underlying
issues it was very good to see that
leaders reiterated their unity
and their support to the fact that
issues must be solved
based on the provisions we have now that
is the trade and corporation agreement
that is the withdrawal agreement and
this includes the protocol
just one focus on the protocol there
should be no doubt
that there is no alternative to the full
and correct implementation
of the protocol and i think it is
important
to reiterate that the protocol is the
only
possible solution to ensure peace and
stability
in northern ireland while protecting the
integrity
of the european union single market
if we see problems today we should not
forget
that they do not come from the protocol
but they result from brexit
that is the reason why the problems are
there now it's our common duty
with the united kingdom to do whatever
we can
to reduce tensions in northern ireland
and that is why we're exploring
practical solutions
to help to minimize the disruptions to
the everyday life in northern ireland
and beyond these current difficulties we
will continue to work on a productive
and balanced relationship
with the united kingdom thanks a lot
thank you madam president we will
exactly take three questions because
at this late or early hour i should say
um and first in first come
from dpa you were first anskar
hi good morning um
good morning a question to
both presidents the measures against
better russian airlines will affect not
only
the supporters of president lukashenko
but also civil society and
people-to-people exchanges
why do you think this decision makes
sense at this time and how do you
explain this decision
to the opponents of lukashenko
thank you
so
population yes we are indeed
we are supporting civil society in
belarus and the support is going on
but there was also a very clear
positioning of
the opposition um that
it would be important for them that
we do not of course support the
government and therefore be very clear
that the eu stands ready to support
belarus when it turns democratic
and in this respect it is also clear
that
the three billion that are
in place ready to go as an economic
or investment package
for belarus will be freeze frozen will
be on hold
as long as the situation is as such
but will be available if belarus turns
democratic
thank you david carretta you're next
thank you very much david radical
italian radio
um two questions i made the first one to
to president
michelle you have spoken of an attack on
european uh
serenity by uh bill russia
uh playing roulette ruth
a russian roulette with uh
citizens i'm wondering on on russia
after all the pattern of the
putin government if you are ready to
take a
more hard position
in fact what are the options that you
expect from
the commission and the high
representative
are sanctions on the table or not and
the question to president from the lion
in your
state of union speech
six or seven months ago speaking about
russia and the navalny case
at a certain point you said that
no pipeline will change the part
the pattern of russia it was
understood as a strong position on
north stream two i'm wondering if you
have
changed your mind if you are
against nordstrom 2 and if you are
asking
the german government to stop the
project thank you very much
the the the first the first question on
on russia uh first you know that uh
we have already taken sanctions against
russia and
on a regular basis we have the
opportunity at the level of the open
council to tackle
the expression of the sanctions this is
my first point but my second point is
the following
we we felt especially the last months
maybe the last years
it was very important to have at the
level of the european council
a in-depth debate an orientation debate
about
this relationship between the eu and
russia
and honestly tonight we had a very
serious
fruitful and useful debate in order to
prepare the next step
and the next step it will be the report
that will be made by the commission and
by the high representative
and we have asked to the commission to
the high representative
to to present a global report a broad
report
about the different areas when it comes
to this relationship between the eu
and russia and also we have asked the
commission
and the high representative to present
to the open council
some policy options and i'm convinced
that this
debate it was an in-depth debate tonight
was also very useful
in order to to listen to each other in
order to reaffirm
our strong unity our strong solidarity
and also in order to reaffirm
the five guiding principles
ursula had expressed what are those five
principles that you know very well and
based on that
based on that we will work more into the
details
in order to have a strategic vision
maybe and i hope a strategic action
towards russia so
when you look at north stream 2 and
the behavior of russia it showed that
many attempts on our side over many many
years
almost decades to improve
the relationship with russia have
not have did not have the success they
deserved
economic cooperation over time it has
gotten
more and more difficult why that because
uh the russian economy is highly
depending
depending on fossil fuels on oil and gas
on energy revenues
and the we have been discussing that the
russian economy at
the beginning of the 2000
um years was
an economy that was in a stage where
they
tried to modernize the economy
using the revenues of oil and gas
in a large scale but to modernize an
economy
you need innovation you need young
people you need
critical minds so over time
the modernization part of the economy
has slowed down
progressively while social
commitments have been made highly
depending again
on the revenues of oil and gas and
what we see tonight today today is an
economy
that is lacking a a an enormous amount
of modernization that would be necessary
an economy that is still highly
depending on energy revenues
but a regime that
is not willing to interact in
a constructive way with us therefore i
think
this way to communicate or this way to
cooperate
on the energy level will not bring any
changes
but we will bring with our report the
different policy options
that will show how we can deal
with russia and in what kind of
relationship we can engage with
different options in the report
i have a last question for luis tovar
from telecinco luis you have the flow
thanks thanks brian bonsoir
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much mr president madam
president
see you all tomorrow morning uh for uh
the resumption of
the second day of the eu co which will
start at 10 o'clock
thank you